because dave you were telling us your
daughters was it harper did she get a
piano lesson oh yeah
years ago i i made friends with paul
mccartney
and um his wife and my wife swapped
numbers so every time he'd come to los
angeles his wife would text my wife and
say hey we're going to dinner would you
like to come to dinner
and of course my wife knows who paul
mccartney is and but i don't know if he
means the same to her as he does to me
he's a beatle you know that's how i
learned how to play music
so we had just had ophelia our youngest
and paul and nancy were in town they
said like okay we want to come see the
new baby she was a week old
so they come over to the house and of
course my kids know who the beatles are
because i brainwashed them when they
were young with all of the beatles music
we have wine pizza and we're hanging out
and it was time for paul to go paul and
nancy were leaving and there's a piano
in the corner of the room
and he just can't help himself you know
so he sits down at the piano and he
starts playing lady madonna
in my [ __ ] house
and i'm just my mind is blown i can't
believe this is happening this is like
the most full circle crazy moment of my
entire life my daughter harper who i
think was five at the time
is watching paul mccartney on the piano
and she goes to the kitchen she gets a
coffee cup
she puts some spare change in it and
puts it on top of the piano like it's a
tip jar
and i thought
she's a girl
and did he then kind of teach her some
chords
he did actually she
she had never uh
she'd never taken a lesson to play any
instrument at that point and she sat
down and she watched his hands
they sat together and he was showing her
what to play
and um
they wrote a song together
as they were doing it it was the only
time i've ever
taken a picture of paul
because to me
i i don't really want to do that i just
want to kind of be his friend you know
yeah
but i saw my daughter getting her first
piano lesson from paul mccartney and i
took a video
the next morning i woke up and i went to
the kitchen i was making breakfast
and i heard her playing the song that
they had written the night before
and i came around the corner and she
looked at me as she was playing the
piano
she realized i was watching
and she never played the piano again oh
for god's sake
and then she's like i want to be a
drummer i'm like are you out of your
mind
[Music]